Hello everyone. I'm Kevin
Belk. Welcome the toxic Google.
And today we have the creative
team behind Disney's new movie,
tomorrow land.
So we'd like to welcome the
director tomorrow land, Mr Brad Bird
and screenwriter.
Damon Lindelof.
Welcome guys. Thanks for being here today.
Thanks. Thanks. Thank you for having us.
So we know bread, uh, from such films,
the writer and director of syndromes such
as a item iron giant, the Incredibles,
Ratatouille, mission impossible
goes protocol and Damon Lindelof,
I was co creator and show runner of ABC's
hit show lost and a is helpful, right?
Such film to stark ended into darkness
and the and whole bunch of stuff.
So welcome guys. Uh, so two of you
guys wrote the script with Jeff Jansen,
but Damien,
you were on the project of a while before
Brad was pulled as a director, right?
Yes. Okay. So what was
the genesis of that?
The idea of it and where this
all kind of come from? Um,
I, uh, I was having
lunch with Sean Bailey,
who's the president of production at
Disney, and we were talking about, um,
uh, what, what is a Disney movie?
They hadn't bought Lucasfilm yet,
but they had marvel and I think that they
understood that they can remake their
animated movies. They were doing
Cinderella, they were doing maleficent.
But what other space was there? And
I said, I'll be honest with you,
when I first heard years ago that you
guys were doing pirates of the Caribbean
as a, uh, as a movie, um, I kind
of turned my nose up at it, but,
but it actually is, it's
sort of genius and, and that,
that's a way to make an original
movie because it's a ride,
but there is no story there. You get
to actually kind of craft the story.
So there's the sandbox,
there's a sandbox. Am I,
my son is eight years old when he
goes on pirates of the Caribbean.
He thinks that the ride is based on the
movie because that's what came first in
his perception.
So he asked me if there was anything
in the park that sparked my interest.
And I said, if there was a movie called
tomorrow land, I would go see it. Um,
and that was kind of the beginning
of a, of the ride. And I,
and I feel like Brad and I had worked
previously and we talked a lot about close
encounters and how they're,
there weren't any movies like
close encounters anymore.
They were just sure wonder awe,
discovering movies.
It's like the plot of that movie is
so simple. Guys see something amazing.
It feels like it means something and
then he just goes in pursuit of it.
It's like,
is that the backbone of a story?
And I think that Jeff and I started
building the iceberg that was going to be
under the water. Um, and once
we had constructed, you know,
how tomorrow land came to be,
I was able to sort of, uh,
coerce a Brad, uh, into,
uh, uh, into, into,
into tiny tip of the iceberg.
Yeah.
Working on the tiny tip of the iceberg
and the code name for it was 1952 up
until 2013 when you guys announced
they would be called tomorrow land.
And so the significance in 1952,
uh,
ut is a little bit in January when you
reveal the mystery box that you guys,
there's a whole story behind that.
And then you went more in
depth with the d 23 expo,
kind of showing the contents,
talking through it.
So can you talk about that kind of bread,
the reveal of that and the teasing of,
well, to me the interesting thing
was that when it was called 1952,
there were all these
very elaborate theories,
which Damon is very used to on
lost, uh, about what it could mean.
But the super interesting thing was that
when we finally revealed that it was
tomorrow and everybody went,
oh,
like they knew what that was like, now I
know what it is. And you would ask them,
okay, what do you think it is?
And they were all over the map,
but they had a feeling that,
that,
you know what the word tomorrow
and means and you know,
that's why we were intrigued by it is
that word tomorrow and means something to
people. And we were trying to kind
of capture that feeling in the movie.
Can you talk about the idea of the box
and the contents that were in it and the
whole kind of reveal of that?
Yeah, I think one of the problems,
particularly if you're not making a
superhero movie or a sequel or something
that is,
you know,
based on a book like the hunger
games or a reboot is people you know,
the same well to where reboot SQL to
a reboot or a reboot of a sequel. MMM.
That sounds good. Uh, is,
is, um, followed by that,
that enthusiasm of, Oh, you
guys are making tomorrow land.
I think that there's the sense of
like, well, what is it? You know,
I need to know what it is.
Like if you want me to come to it.
And we hadn't started shooting the
movie yet. And I think that we,
we needed something to show people we
needed to give people a sense of what the
movie was going to be.
And since all the things that we were
talking about was a while a Walt Disney
early imagineering, the world's fairs,
particularly the 1964 world's fair. We,
we, in the same way that when you
go to Disneyland or Disney world,
you have to wait in line for, you know,
an hour or 90 minutes while you're online.
There's a story being told to you before
you go on the ride for two and a half
minutes. And the box was really sort
of our line experience. So it was like,
let's put, you know, let's,
let's take the things out of this box
that are going to begin to get people a
sense of the movie and the story
that we're telling. Interesting.
So what was the process of
weaving and kind of, you know,
history and real life elements with a
Scifi film because of the movie is based
on obviously, you know, it doesn't
the park's property, but you,
that's not really it. I mean, you know,
a, it's not even a ride. It's a land.
So it's a lot more wispy. Uh,
what it's about for us. I mean,
it's not about the,
the theme park at all.
It's about what does that world mean to
you? What does that word mean to you?
You know, tomorrow is a, is an a
femoral word. It's, it's vague,
but it's coming and it's, there's hope,
you know, and land is Tara from it.
Solid. And, and the, the crashing
together of those two words is,
is there's something happens.
And,
and I think we were in pursuit of
how do we wrap a story around that?
Something that could happen.
Interesting. So, and you, you,
so you have a low experience brand cause
you went from, um, you know, doing, uh,
original work with the Incredibles
and Ratatouille and you know, you've,
you've talked a little bit about maybe
visiting the world again with Incredibles
two and that's a sequel,
but what,
what was it like kind of going
with the original property,
you just kind of take
the name tomorrow land,
but you're doing a completely
original world in live action.
How was that transition? Well, that
was just really exciting to me. I mean,
because I, I make a point
of kind of, you know,
regularly saying that I think the movie
industry dedicates too much bandwidth,
a big budget bandwidth to
ideas that are too, you know,
that are familiar. Uh, I think
people simplify that into, oh,
he doesn't like sequels. It's obvious
that I liked sequels. I just did one, I'm,
I'm about to do another one. Some of my
favorite movies are sequels, but I, uh,
a lot of my favorite experiences in,
in movie theaters are films where I
don't know what's going to happen.
And then star wars at one point was a
really weird radical idea that very few
people got.
And George Lucas had to fight every
step of the way to get it made.
E T I don't think people were ready for,
I mean they clearly were ready for,
but they didn't know what it
was when it first came out.
And those are wonderful experiences
to have at a movie, uh, uh, theater.
And, and when Damon mentioned this
idea to me, I was leaning forward,
I wanted to know, uh, about this
place and what could happen there.
And so I was,
I was really happy to join.
So was there any pressure from the
studio just kind of to incorporate more
tomorrow? Land space, mountain, stuff
like that? It was just kinda like, no, no,
it was at, it was actually the
opposite. I think early on we said, hey,
just so you know that there's probably
not going to be a space mountain in this,
in this movie because it
does feel like it's the,
it's the thing you need to check off.
And again,
to go back to pirates of
the Caribbean. Um, the,
the idea that like there's a little Easter
egg in the movie where there's a dog
holding the keys in its mouth and you
kind of go like, oh, that's from the ride.
But it, you know, it's, it's
more of a wink and a nod.
Space Mountain makes a glimpse.
Yes. Right. You see the structure,
but there's no like set piece.
Right. But I think that ultimately,
especially when you're talking about a
new piece of Ip or an original movie,
we actually,
we don't need to sell tickets to the park.
The park needs to sell tickets
to tomorrow land. Um, and,
and so they were completely in totally
on board with that idea. That's great.
And so was there,
cause I think the visual is still though,
but you kind of took a lot of the visuals
from tomorrow land, which was awesome.
I thought like a little bit. It's more
of a feeling. Yeah. But, but again,
we were not, you know, they, they
were incredibly supportive of us.
That's being free range chickens.
No.
And I tomorrow land is one of my
freelance ranger tickets. Yeah.
Uh, but tomorrow, tomorrow land is
one of my favorite parts of the park.
But I do think that a, even from when I
first went there when I was 11 years old,
always struggled with
identity in terms of,
is it the Jules Verne tomorrow
land that's sort of based in,
in the late 19th century?
You know, is it? Well,
I think the thing that's
interesting about it, um, is, uh,
Disney essentially designed that one
section of the park to be perpetually
frustrating to businessmen because
you can never be done with tomorrow.
Tomorrow is always in motion.
And so it's the one part of the park
that's going to go out of date relatively
quickly if you don't keep reinventing it.
And I think during the Eisenhower era,
they, they dealt with it by like,
I can't we just be done. You know,
they dealt with it by putting it in
the past and hopefully we're done.
And I think that kind of, now there's an
impatience to do something new with it.
I mean,
you go into a imagineering and they're
chomping at the bit to reinvent it
because I think they're
more, uh, uh, you know,
excited about the wall type idea where,
where it's continually coming. It's not,
uh, a galaxy far, far away.
It's, you know, it's, it's uh,
something that, that actually may
happen and it's coming and, and uh,
you know, I think that they're
invigorated by that idea. And, and listen,
I would love a star wars land as well,
but I don't think it's the same thing.
I think there's star wars land and
there's tomorrow land and though they're
separate things and they do separate
things. And I would be excited about both.
And I think what's crazy is if you think
about the future as projected from the
60s with flying cars and jet packs
and you know, gleaming metropolis is,
did we decide on what the plural was,
is a metropolis Shawmut metropolises the,
the,
that still hasn't manifested itself.
So the Jetsons still feels like a sh
it's a show about the future in the year
2015,
we were just kind of nuts and we still
don't have our jet packs were guys do.
Yeah, you guys maybe I saw
some parked outside. Yeah.
And so in you give them the animation
world. So you went to cal arts,
your college Grad,
and you start,
you had your time with the Simpsons and
it does mean, and so kind of what was,
what did you learn kind of from animation
that you're able to take into live
action? What was difficult?
What was easy? Well, what,
what's funny is when I
did animation exclusively,
everybody kept talking about how it felt
like live action and then you go into
live action and they got, well, it feels
kind of like animation and it's like,
it's all just film to me.
And, and uh, you know,
I am excited about both mediums and the
cynical animation friends I had is that
when I did mission impossible,
they're like, ah, you're
never coming back. You're,
you're so happy to be sick
seated at the grownups table.
You're never coming back. And unlike,
no, I love the animation. So, uh,
I would,
my ideal career would just be bouncing
back between the back and forth between
the two because I think they're
both great ways to tell stories.
And the kids table is more fun anyway.
You get grow food and, exactly.
Chicken fingers. Well like I don't
want to talk about know there's a,
there's a clip
out there that's a,
there's a,
it's a beautiful hand drawn animated short
film that was released the origins of
Plus Ultra and uh,
you,
it was animated by amazing ours to Newton
and Energy Mendez and Ryan Woodward
blue at Montereau, Dan Jupe,
Paul, uh, Abdellah. So was that,
that was so interesting
and it was so cool.
Was there ever any interest
in point in that in the movie
designed initially to be a sort of,
um,
first step in designing a dark ride
that the lead character as a child,
the George Clooney character as a child
goes through and it was going to be done
as if it were a ride made
in that period of time.
And we use that as like the starting
point. Okay, here, here are the ideas.
Here's the way it looks.
Now we've got to put it in a ride.
Contacts and Ilm started doing it,
but we couldn't get away from the fact
that it was our lead character watching
something, uh, you know,
being told to him and it's kind of stopped
the story debt and it's great in and
of itself. I mean, as, as I think it's
interesting, but in context of the movie,
it stopped the movie.
So we decided to just kind of separate
it and put it out there separately.
But it is kinda good to know. I
mean, it's good backstory stuff.
You guys haven't seen it. I'll look
it up. It's really, really great.
And so [inaudible] Damon, you
know, there's a lot, you know,
this movie is huge and it's complex.
And, and what I love about the movies,
you really don't spend a lot of time. It's
fun. It's so, oh my gosh, that's so much.
Everyone's like to ride the hi Fi.
Uh,
it's a plate full of vegetables.
I don't know if I like that. Yeah.
But there's a, there's a great balance
because you're not spending, you know,
30 to 60 minutes of exposition. You
know, you just get right into it.
Like you get right into the world's
fairs where kind of the story begins and
your, um, you know,
then get right into tomorrow land and
it's great because it's a slow burn,
the slow reveal over
time and it's engaging.
So what's the balance of not giving
the audience on spoonfeeding them and
talking down to them,
but like really kind of keeping it
engaging and keeping that balance,
getting it in the popcorn?
Exactly.
Yeah. I think that we really struggled
with that and the storytelling, you know,
the, the writing of it, it felt
like we had found the right balance.
But then after we made the movie and got
into the editing room, I think that the,
you know, is Brad, Brad was, was sort
of hinting at, there's that idea of, um,
can I follow this story without having
it explained to me? And when you,
when you go off the rails there,
you need to stop and have a little bit
of explanation or else the audience gets
confused.
But then there's a line that you cross
and it's razor thin where you're,
you've suddenly explained too
much and you're in, you know,
you're in the second matrix movie and
the architect is basically like neo,
I'm going to break it down for you.
I'm going to basically tell you everything
that happened in the first matrix
movie, everything that's
happening in this make movie.
And then I'll tell you everything that's
going to happen in the third matrix
movie. And then you heard the
temp Rhoda. So I mean, and I,
and I do feel,
obviously we wanted to make a movie
that was about something had, um, that,
that had a strong theme to
it and made people think,
but ultimately it's a Disney movie.
It's coming out in the summer. You know,
we want people to, this is, he's
enjoying his popcorn. He's drinking,
he's drinking a soda, more popcorn. He
is, something's gone down the wrong pipe.
He's clapping,
he's scared.
I don't feel like I'm on
Pictionary is terrifying. Um,
but, uh, uh, but yeah, we wanted to
make the movie really entertaining.
And I do think that it's hard
to say we want to, you know,
we want this movie to appeal to eight
year olds and we want it also want it to,
to appeal to 68 year olds. Um, it feels
like there's a lot of room in between,
but I, but I do feel ultimately
that that's the movie that we made.
Well,
I think that the,
the films that both of us are inspired
by or ones that are a blast to watch,
but later on you're thinking about them,
you know, and there's nothing wrong with,
with, um, you know, uh,
remembering a song, you know, um,
you know, and, and loving
it when you're hearing it,
but also thinking about it later.
And so we had attempted to
make that and we would love to,
you know, think that we
had, but you never know.
You just try your best and
see what happens tomorrow.
And it really drives home the theme
of innovation and exploration.
And it seems to be really inspiring the
children of today to just imagine all
the ways that they can help
create a better tomorrow. I
mean, the theme is really,
really driven home. So, you know,
in today's world where there's so much
technology for children, you know,
at the click of a button, um, you
know, was that ever intentional,
kind of the common theme throughout it
and kind of pushing that all the way.
Yeah.
I mean, I think simply put there, you
know, there's a very Disney Disney,
a idea at the, at the core of this,
which is when you wish upon a star,
your dreams come true.
But we,
but what are you willing to
do once you've made the wish?
Yeah. You don't lie down and
let the dream, you know, happen.
There's a line in the film where the
George Clooney character is a kid and, uh,
he has built a jet pack and,
uh,
the Athena character,
who is our secret weapon,
and we're not going to talk about
her too much, but check it out. Uh,
she says to him, um, did you build this
yourself? And he says yes, and she says,
why?
And he says,
I guess I got tired of waiting around
for someone else to build it for me.
And that's really, that's the key
step two of the dreaming ideas.
It's wonderful to have a dream, but you,
you then have to give the dream action.
You can't lay down and,
and hope that it's going to happen.
As you guys all know this, that's
totally what you do every day. So,
and an on a slightly more metal level,
I think that we were just
sitting around saying,
I wish there were more original movies
and I wish there was a movie when I went
to go see it. I didn't know exactly what
was going to happen. Right. You know,
when some interstellar, which came
out, you know, while we were in post,
I just was so excited to see that movie
because I didn't know what it was going
to be. Um, and, uh, we could
either sit around sort of, um,
decrying the, the fall of
Western civilization, or
we could try to, you know,
guys like Brad have earned, um,
uh, well, I mean, in the, in the,
in the movie world,
you have to have a great success and that,
and then you can go and make an original
movie. But the offers that you get,
it is,
it is all sequels and comic books.
And those are the movies that
are sort of proven. There's a,
there's much less risk now. They
are. Yeah. Yeah. Now they are right.
You have to keep reminding them that
these were actually original movies that
was scary to people like you at one
point, you know, and they go, Whoa,
no star wars. There's always been,
I had, it's like not admiral ackbar.
So yeah,
it's good. I love that. As far
as star wars apologist, yeah.
He
told magnates shaped bones.
That's fully got by ratio though.
There's no segue into this,
but so young, uh, frank, uh, but,
uh, but you touched upon the young,
uh, Frank Walker, a character
played by Thomas Robinson.
We're going to do the rest of this
interview as Burlap Park that will get the
views on youtube,
are going to shoot,
do hear bird did it in a sit down at
Google as ackbar for two hours and he
wouldn't break character.
We couldn't get him off in 15
minutes on Mon Calamari. Yeah.
Believable. So Frank Walker, uh,
sorry. No, you're good. You're good.
The entire beginning of the movie movie,
you know,
it's so much fun to watch cause it Kinda
brought me back to my childhood of just
being fun and going out and exploring
and just goofing off and, and it's,
you know,
with his character building that jetpack
and coming up with that and just being
so inspired and went back to the movies,
kind of like Goonies and,
and stand by me.
So what were your inspirations and how
would you capture that childhood spirit
is because you kind of our children
at heart or kind of what was,
what was kind of putting that, getting
that right? I think w you know, uh,
it was very hard. I mean, we
have plenty of wounds, you know,
along the way to get in the position
where we're in. But we, you know,
knock on wood, we thank our lucky
stars that were in a position to,
to tell stories and, and you know, uh,
I think that we both grew up with
storytelling being a great place to,
to digest the world. And, and, uh,
that part of storytelling has
always been there, you know,
when it was campfire stuff.
Um,
so just a chance to do it is just amazing.
And I also think that it was really
important to us to start the movie in the
60s because we were,
when,
whenever we went out into the
world and talked about the movie,
there was this sense that in the,
in the 1960s,
sort of in the heat of the space
race, despite the fact that, you know,
the world was in turmoil, the Cold War
was happening. We were on the brink of a,
of annihilation assassination. It was
just a very turbulent time. But still,
everyone's vision for the
future was, was utopian. And,
and now it feels like there's been
a shift into, into dystopia where,
why did that happen? You
know, I mean, we were,
had a lot of conversations about
what made that go away because it's,
it's kind of like,
you know how they deal with a lobster
where they put it in cold water and
gradually turn up the volume
and it doesn't know that
it's being cooked to death.
It's like,
when did this happen?
When did it become common wisdom
that the future was going to suck?
And the only point of view that
seems realistic is, is a dark one.
What change the worlds, you know, bad.
It has a lot of bad stuff going on,
but it's no worse than it was back then.
And so we were kind of talking about how
can we explore that in a sort of fair
fable like way. And you have popcorn
crunch in good times, right? Yeah. Yes.
And I mean, just touching upon this to
your casting choices are incredible.
I mean with,
with Rafi Cassidy and Britt Robertson,
it was Athena and Casey Newton.
And I wanna talk a little bit about the
character names. Not go too deep into it,
but, um, especially with Newton, that's,
it seems like an obvious tribute
to Sir Isaac Newton. Yeah, sure.
Just a or a caddy. Yeah, exactly. And,
or the fig big fan.
And we'll skip over Athena
cause I know that's a,
but obviously the Greek goddess.
Well,
I think the thing that's fun about
the cast is, is that we have, um,
people that the public knows very well,
like,
like George Clooney and
Hugh Laurie and Tim Mcgraw.
And at the same time we have these brand
new faces like Britt Robertson and Rafi
Cassidy. So it's really a popery
and Keegan Michael Key and,
uh, Kathryn Hall, Kathryn Hahn.
And it just, it's, it's a really,
it's a salad bar of cool performances.
Yeah. Well, I mean, George,
can we say in an ice cream bar,
ice cream bar,
the salad bar here, it was, was
very popular. I have to say,
much more traffic than the
dessert bar. Um, so, you know,
George Clooney's character,
the interesting thing about Walker
is when you first introduced him,
he's pretty grumpy and he's a
little curmudgeony and stuff.
And what was interesting was
that throughout the movie
you just started to like
a more and more and more.
So kind of what was that balance?
Was it a risk or was there any kind of
pushback of kind of introducing him? Like,
you're not going to like, I'm kind
of at first, so he gets grumpy,
but he gets better and better and better
and all of a sudden you find out why he
is that way. Yeah, I think
that they're, you know, it's a,
it's a story that we're
familiar with and um, and,
and well told it always works,
which is that, you know,
someone's a bit of a
curmudgeon. Um, and if this,
if the story in this season and this
case is about how do they get to be that
way? And again, as you say this, the
story starts with this young boy,
he grows up to be that way and
you kind of wonder what happened.
And then he becomes sort of a functioning
metaphor for this idea that Brad was
just talking about between, you
know, how we feel about the future.
So this young kid is super idealistic.
I do think that the older we get,
the more pragmatic we become,
the harder it is for us to
say everything's going to
work out fine because we,
we, we start to understand
life for what it is.
And so the movie is really about kind of
returning George back to, you know, that,
that sort of childhood sense of wonder
that we demonstrated at the beginning of
the movie. Great. And he's an optimistic
guy. I mean, um, I, I think he, uh,
he plays a great grump, but, um,
he's definitely a guy who does
not accept the status quo. No,
it's that can check Czechoslovakia. It's
called great. Grump the movie. Yeah,
I didn't know that. There we
go. Roughly translated. Yeah.
Um, and I want to talk a little
about the visuals of the film. Uh,
the first establishing
shot up tomorrow land.
We as soon as a lot into teasers and
the trailers and it's on the posters and
stuff,
you know,
Newton in the field looking onto the city
really reminded me of the wizard of Oz
when Dorothy and the gang are kind
of looking onto the city. So, uh,
did that have a lot of inspiration of
what films kind of inspired this? Well,
that,
yeah.
Moment where the character touches the
pen and finds herself in the wheat field
was part of the film when Damon pitched
me the idea and that idea that this
better world was that close, that it
was, it was essentially just a, uh,
on the other side of an invisible
veil, uh, was really attractive to me.
I mean,
without getting pretentious on it,
it's also on a metaphoric level is that
that better future is closer than we
think. And it's not an
impossible place to get to it.
It's going to take work and it's gonna
take some sacrifice as it does in the
film and in its own fairy tale
way. But, uh, it is that close. It,
it can happen. It's, it's tangible.
And you know, uh, in the 60s,
which we are talking about, uh, you know,
President Kennedy said we're going to be
on the moon by the end of this decade.
And it happened, you
know, so, uh, you know,
we were just kind of trying to PR
you should talk about,
I was just going to,
I think that a big part of it
is ultimately we're trying,
I was just talking with a gentleman
in the back before we went on about,
you know, what, what is the
emotional idea behind it? Um,
because it's hard to describe a feeling
and that idea of tomorrow and really
represents a feeling that we
have. And, and, and how do
you visualize that feeling?
And I think that the idea of you kind
of need somebody to show you what you're
working toward as a motivator.
And it's like,
we want you to know that this place
exists. This is why we built it.
It's an inspiration.
It's going to be very hard to get there,
but if you put your mind to
it, you can. And it exists.
And I think that that's one
of the reasons that, um,
that pop culture is so obsessed with
dystopia is it's easier to build because
all you have to do is knock down what
we've got. You know, it's, it's easy to,
it's easy to knock down cities that
are preexisting or, or put, you know,
as much as I love blade runner, it
was an inspirational movie. It's,
it's grafted onto an existing complex.
Um,
for us it's much harder
to build the future.
And it was an immensely challenging for
Brad and his entire team to basically
say like, okay, we know what
looks like from this far away,
but she's going to actually have to go
into that city and what does it look like
from the ground up?
Yeah. But on another level, on
a more abstract level, you know,
I go through that same thing with
ideas all the time. You know,
when ideas are brand new, they are
fragile things and you're just going,
I don't know what this is
exactly, but here, you know,
maybe it's this and you can knock it
down like that and most people do.
Um, but, uh,
so it's easier to knock down an idea than
it is to protect it and nurture it and
help it get strong. You know, there,
there is that tendency, you know,
negativity is like a weed that that has
really hardy and doubt is. And you know,
we're in show business where it's like
doubt is always the character, you know,
in the room and it's the Alpha in the
room and you kind of have to win every
time. You know, I mean,
you can literally go through every line
of Casablanca and do it as if it's a bad
line, you know, of all the gin
joints in the world, you know,
you can make any ideas sound bad
and it's easy to do. And, and,
you know, the, the Internet is
powerful. It is as it is, is a,
as a way to learn and everything.
It's also a way to snark from the shadows
and kill a positive things in their,
in their cradle.
So it's like,
I think that the film supports
the idea of nurturing, you know,
uh, uh, new ideas and, um,
try taking the hits it you need to
take to make something positive happen.
Yeah.
Uh,
well this is a great transition to Dana
who was with our toxic Google program as
well, and she's going
to come up here and, uh,
take us through something special
that, uh, Google help create with, uh,
the Disney marketing team.
Yes. So, uh, we're very excited because
Disney and Google partner to create,
take me to tomorrow land,
which is a 363 interactive experience.
Uh, so you can visit it by
going to take me to tomorrow,
land.com or you can use Google voice
search technology and say, okay, Google,
take me to tomorrow land. Uh, so
we have a very quick demo here. Um,
if you guys want to, you know,
give us any tidbits in commentary,
you're more than welcome to
give you a good visual of the world
that they created and stuff. And,
and this is all done by, you know, the
Disney kind of marketing side of it,
but they can't take a lot of
inspiration and aspects, uh,
from the film that these guys credit.
Yeah. Great. Uh, you know, uh,
not having seen the precise
demo that you're about to show.
I think that we just wanted to try
to create the experience that, uh,
that the characters who
touched the pins have,
which is that you could essentially,
you'll look through your cell phone,
I'm at this virtual space and understand
that like there's a thin layer between
our world and this other world
and that it would be 360 degrees.
So depending on which direction you turn,
you would be getting a vista into, um,
into tomorrow land and you could actually
venture into the city in the same way.
Illustration of that idea that
it's that close, you know?
Yeah, Yup. Go ahead.
You've represent the very best and most
imagine you said the world has to offer
and that is why do you have
been selected to visit tomorrow?
Land secret pace and
nothing is impossible. Pace,
where your dreams for
the future come reality.
If you're ready to change the world,
we need to do.
So. That was Athena, right?
That's the thing is voice.
And then obviously this
display is, you actually, uh,
I showed this to some writers on the
show that I work on and they were all
started spinning around in their chairs
and you have to see the city that's
behind you. And then you go in and there's
a variety of, of great content. Um,
this is a little short on the
1964 world's fair, um, where,
uh, where Walt was a
pervasive presence. He had a,
uh, audio item Medtronics there,
Mr Lincoln carousel progress. Yeah.
For attractions that were all
kind of futuristic and themselves.
And then this is, um, this
is, this is our, uh, uh,
view of tomorrow land. A lot of which, um,
which is in the real world was shot
in the city of arts and sciences.
[inaudible] Spain,
uh,
designed by a kind of genius
architect named Calatrava. Okay.
Uh, that was a little
piece of, um, of, uh,
a letter from David Nix who is Hugh
Laurie. And the movie to Steve Jobs, um,
who were saying was a
member of Plus Ultra.
I think one of the fun parts of the viral
for our campaign is we imagined who in
the last hundred years would have been in,
in the Secret Society of,
of geniuses and thinkers. Um, what
architects, uh, what storytellers,
uh, what mathematicians,
et Cetera, et Cetera,
because we always likened tomorrow
land to sort of, ah, ha, you know,
Hogwarts for science. Um, this,
this secret world that was created by the
best and brightest. Right. But it's not,
it's,
it's scientists and artists and you know,
I think, uh, you know, Hetty
Lamar is, is in plus ultra.
Yeah.
That's pretty cool.
Hmm.
And these are just a number
of different of bus stops.
So there's a lot of fun stuff to
explore and kick around. Um, there,
there's a sequence in the movie,
uh, that relates to where, okay,
I'm not going to give it
away, but I will, hey,
you guys have Ralph
Kramden over here. Uh, uh,
we'll just say that there've
been things police in Paris.
There are many worlds fairs. Uh, yes. Uh,
one in 1889 there was a
particular interest interest
to us.
And was it all a fun to kind of connect
the history with the movie and kind of,
well, I think that one of the
things that was interesting is, um,
world's fairs used to be a place where
people kind of bright ideas together from
all over the world and kind of showed off,
you know, how they imagine the future.
And what's interesting is,
uh,
their visions of the future were different
depending on which era they were from.
But they all still look
futuristic. I mean, the future in,
in the late 18 hundreds was full of air
ships that were like giant balloons,
you know, because that's what they
could imagine, you know. And in the 20s,
it was Hugh Ferris in these,
these massive buildings that were blocks
and blocks long and wide at the base,
um, but just stretched into the heavens.
And it was kind of like metropolis,
you know, that fits Fritz
Lang movie. And uh, so,
so the visions of the future, we're
always changing, but they were all,
they all still look futuristic. So
we were kind of saying, you know,
what if a skyline was built up of, uh,
you know, futuristic detail from a lot of,
and we only get to touch on it in the
movie. It's really kind of a road movie.
But anyway, yeah. Thank you
for all that. That was amazing.
A little director's
screenwriter commentary. Uh,
so Dana has some extra questions that
we've collected from Googlers and she's
going to go into those and then we're
gonna go into live audience questions.
So if you guys want to start
lining up the mic, great. Uh,
yeah. So take it dinner. So these are
some questions we've collected. Uh,
and you guys have briefly
mentioned this, but, uh,
what's one technology from tomorrow
land that you wish we could have today?
Well, the easy answer is jetpacks
we're still waiting. Yeah.
But, uh, yeah, I mean,
you know, I, you know, I,
I do think that ultimately
technology is great, um,
in terms of a bettering the human
condition, but I also think as,
as one of our characters expresses in
the movie, that it should be fun. Yeah.
And I think that the things that I
gravitate to a tech technology wise, um,
are fun. And, uh, we tried to
pop the weight the movie with,
with stuff that may or may on the surface
be a bit impractical but had great
user interface. But I think
that, yeah. But I think that,
thank you sir. That's, yeah.
One guy. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, but I think to that
kind of the Disney aspect of it too
is, is, you know, people say, well,
is it in the park? Is it, is
it while Disney in the movie?
And it's like he isn't and it isn't,
but it's kind of all over the film
if it's about a state of mind and,
and Disney viewed the future
as exciting and, and fun and,
and full of wonder. It's not something
that is crushing or anything like that.
Um,
and you guys touched on this a little bit,
but what are some of the challenges
of appealing to such a broad audience?
You know, you want six year olds through
68 year olds going to the movie. Uh,
and Damien,
especially some of your work has maybe
geared towards a slightly older audience.
Uh,
was there any fun?
It's a dealing with that
or I think the challenge
is that if you start aiming at any
group that you are not a member of,
you're in trouble. If you start
saying they'll love it, you're dead.
And I think that if you think about it
logically as it was we were talking about
right before this, uh, the idea of
your, your job, here's your assignment,
sir,
is to make something that will
appeal to all ages and all,
uh, uh, both sexes and
everything in between. And, uh,
uh, all parts of the world,
all faiths, all non faiths,
four years from now, three years
from now, that's your goal.
It's like it's an impossible job. No one
in their right mind would ever do it.
But if you make the job,
what do I want to see at the movies,
then the job becomes doable and
simple. So I think that, you know,
speaking for myself, um, uh,
I just tried to make a movie that I would
want to see and then hopefully other
people share that. And, you know, Eh,
simply put, I think that I spend a
lot of my time in dark territory.
I'm really drawn to those stories as
a consumer and as a storyteller. Um,
and as much as we decried the dystopian
movies that tomorrow land is sort of
against, I love those movie. Yeah.
A lot of them. So these are great,
but I wanted to make them,
you know,
but I really want to do engage
in something where, where it,
I felt good and um, and it was lighter
and brighter or without being corny.
And I think that the idea of saying,
well,
I really think that people want to
go see the movies, go to the movies,
especially in the summer,
and walk out of it with a smile on their
face and not scratching their heads.
And that doesn't mean that it needs
to be dumb and that doesn't need that.
It can't be a dark journey along the way.
But I do think that the,
the journey towards optimism is it was
something that we were aspiring to.
And as stupid as it is to say this,
it is true that that brings every,
at every age group,
every gender, you know,
every ethnicity under the sun who
doesn't want to see that. Yeah.
And we don't know,
but everybody loves dystopia,
but they don't want to live in one.
Yeah. And, and, and for me, you were
talking about, um, uh, you know, uh,
appealing to different, uh,
different aspects. Um, you know,
my work in animation has been geared a
little more towards the adult side of
things as well.
And yet when I was a kid,
I liked to entertainment that I didn't
completely understand that there was,
you know, bugs bunny wasn't
actually designed for children.
A lot of people made the mistake
of thinking that it was, um,
but it actually was designed for the
people that we're going to see the latest
Bogart movie as a little mint beforehand.
And so the jokes are
absolutely adult jokes.
And that doesn't mean that a kid
won't have a good time at it.
But it means that when you get older,
the films also grow old
with you and they go, hey,
I got one for Ya that you didn't get
when you were a kid. And I like that.
The next question is about the score
and working with Michael Cicchino. Uh,
you both worked with him before. Yeah, no.
Yeah. Well actually introduced us.
Yeah, that's right. Um, my, uh,
Michael did the score for lost
all six seasons and um, and,
and also I guess he was working on the
Incredibles first movie was incredible.
They overlapped a bit and then he did
the music for speed racer and Brad and I
were both at the speed mace
racer premiere, and then
he introduced us and, uh,
we pushed him aside and started
geeking out. Uh, but it,
it's actually been a dream
come true because, you know,
Michael doesn't just write the music.
He's a, he's a real creative collaborator.
He's a storyteller. And that's why, uh,
I think that's why we enjoy his music
is he has all the compositional chops,
but he's not just making music.
He's telling a story with us and he,
and he writes incredibly emotional music.
I think that the idea of like he really
makes you feel something when you close
your eyes and you think about up, you
know, you can literally hear that. Yeah,
that theme in your heart. Yeah.
Yeah. No, it's, it's really,
it's almost an eerie tone too.
It's really,
really cool what they've done
with the on the edge of the city.
We have one more question before we turn
it over to our live audience and that
is in cinematic history.
What film do you wish you could
have directed or written? Oh my God,
you haven't already.
It's just a 24 hour network.
Can be
a Damon.
There's too many for him it feels
like it's a trick question. I mean,
because those movies wouldn't be as
good had I written or directed them.
That's not putting myself down.
It's just saying like, you know,
jaws is probably, as much as I love
star wars and Raiders of the lost arc,
those are the,
those are the two movies that I saw
billions and billions of time times.
I think the first time that I saw
jaws, jaws, I was just in wonder.
I was really aware of
the filmmaking in a way,
the decisions that were being made.
Um, uh, directorially and I, uh,
I, I just think that, you
know, essentially it's just
a movie about a shark that's,
uh, needs to be stopped.
But the, but the, you know,
but the complexity is every
single scene in that movie,
the choices that are being
made. There's a, you know,
there's a scene that Jj has talked about
between Roy Scheider and a son where
they're just sort of, uh, you know,
my each other. And it's like, it,
that scene is all emotion about how
these characters are feeling emotionally.
And I just think that they're, you know,
that, that that's a directorial decision.
It happens on the page. It
happens organically. And I
think this, this idea of,
I'm just trying not to overthink things
and go from the gut, go from the gut. Um,
yeah. And, and you know, I mean, you,
he says those films and it's just
like each time I'm like, ha ha.
Because they're great films and they
stick with you, you know, um, uh,
there's, uh, in Raiders, you know,
is there a better ending to a film than
that guy wheeling the thing into the
warehouse? Endless. I mean,
that's just, you know,
and it's like, that's what
makes you want to get, you know,
you see a crappy movie and you
just go, oh, movies are over.
They're just like, ah,
you know, I came too late.
The art forums played out and
I've gotten in the habit of like,
[inaudible] got a mild creative poisoning
somehow and I need to fix it and I put
on any great movie and watch 10 minutes
of that and man, I'm ready again.
You know,
I watched the opening of a once upon a
time in the west and it just makes you go
westerns rock, you know, and I can't
wait to do a western, you know?
So anyway. Yeah, no.
Piggybacking off that a little bit
because pet man's wallet recently did that
little rant about,
um,
if there was a movie that has
not had a SQL and is like, what,
what would you like to see made?
And he wanted to see the unbreakable
SQLs so is there a movie from the past,
like pitch the entire, the entire
thing and I was going to make it with,
I'm not shambling I have
weird things like, you know,
I want to see Ambersons wells
cut of Ambersons. You know, I,
I want to see, I would love it
if I could just put Sean Connery,
take him out of diamonds are
forever and put him in, you know,
on Her Majesty's secret service that
have that be your last bond film.
You know what I mean? Um, so it's a lot of
that kind of super geek stuff. You know,
I kind of feel that movies that don't
have sequels shouldn't have sequels, um,
equal to the castle.
Because back then,
did you know that I did not
know about bill. Yeah. Wow.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm not kidding.
No,
but I,
and this isn't to take anything away from
back to the future two or back to the
future three, but I think that, you know,
doc Brown at the end saying, you know,
there's something wrong with your kids,
Marty, and then the, and then the ants,
you know, and then it's
like, what's wrong?
What's wrong with his kids is that
they're assholes. If you know,
like that's the big payoff
is like, no, it wasn't meant.
It wasn't meant to be taken literally.
There wasn't supposed to be
a back to the future too.
And so every once in a
while you hear like, oh,
I hear they're talking about
an e t two and it's like, why?
Why do you need that to
happen? I mean like, do I do,
I name God Spielberg has made sure
that hasn't had, yeah, no, it's great.
And it's just protecting that one.
So if a movie was great then
and there isn't a sequel by now,
they're probably shouldn't be.
Yup. Yup. Great. So I think we're going
to turn it over to a lot of questions.
So given your different backgrounds,
expertise,
what was your process for providing input
to the visual designers for the film,
which is very important to this film.
And Brad,
thank you very much for
the photo of my daughter.
That was incredibly cool yesterday.
Oh, thank you. Uh, well it was, it was,
it was tough because as we just said,
um,
the tip is all we of the iceberg is all
we could show in this movie and there
just wasn't enough time. You know,
at the beginning of a film, you, you,
it's a wide open and you feel
like you can go forever on it,
but the story only allowed x amount of
time and tomorrow land because the story
is not about the city. It's
about the journey. And so,
uh, as, as fun as the city
was to, to, to create,
there are all these things
that I would love to do that,
that we just didn't have
enough screen time for. So,
and yeah, and for me, speaking
outside of a visual medium,
and I'm kind of saying the same
thing that, that, that Brad just was,
is that the city, it's really
about what the city represents.
It's about capturing that feeling. Cause
if you think about Oz, for example, this,
the,
the emerald city and I were to start
actually seeing her and I were to say to
you like,
just tell me anything about the
emerald city, like an adjective. Other
than that, it's green and you, you're,
you're hard pressed to do so because it's
really about, it's, it's a destination.
It's where the wizard is.
If the place that you're trying
to get to that in your mind,
it's this amazing place in your,
you swear you've seen it in detail,
but that's more about the spell they,
we've, than it is about the actuality.
You know, people talk about Bambi,
you know, and they go, man, every,
every leaf in that forest
is perfect. Actually, if you
see the film, it's not, it's,
it's almost abstract.
They have very little detail and they
only have little points of detail,
which is the genius of
the art direction of it.
And I think it's the difference between
the director's cut of close encounters
and the, and the, and
the theatrical release,
which is you don't need to
go inside the ship, you know,
although he did a cut afterwards
where you don't go in the shit. Right.
Cause he realized that was not
a good idea. That's what I'm,
I think we're saying the same thing.
What I'm saying is there's,
there's the director's cut after
the director's cut. I understand.
I see your geeky and I'd raise it.
I fold.
Wow.
I bring it up.
Me Too.
If you were put in charge of Disneyland,
what would you change tomorrow? Land.
Yeah, I would, and I've talked to the
Disney guys about it. I mean they, uh,
you know, it's, it's, it's like a
country, they change administrations.
And I think there's enthusiasm
in this administration for, uh,
taking on the challenge of tomorrow. And
I think the previous administration, uh,
was frustrated by Walt basically creating
a part of the park that had to be
continually reinvented.
He designed it to be continually going
out of date and needing refreshing more
than any other land in the park because
he was excited about that idea. But,
uh, uh, the,
the usual businessman is frustrated by
that at that idea because it means that
you've constantly got to work on it and
it's like, can't we just be done? And,
and that,
uh,
the version of tomorrow land that has
been there for a while is kind of trying
to, to end the reinvention of it.
Like we'll put it in the past,
it'll be Jules Verne ask and then we'll
be done. And I think the current, uh,
a group of imagineers are very
excited about the possibility of,
of reinvigorating it and making it again,
a place that's an idea
that's about to come,
which is really exciting about tomorrow
land in Walt Disney's conception.
And I think is, is the key
to making it work. Ditto.
Thank you. And a Brad, which
of your previous work should
have a sequel of mine?
Is it batteries?
Not included?
Wow. Uh, well, uh, I'm,
I think they did make a sequel
to batteries, not included.
Didn't they direct to video? No,
no, no, no. That doesn't count. No.
Hmm. Uh, I'm currently
writing Incredibles two, so
I'm not averse to a
sequel or too, but no, no,
I'm not going to say that
damn thing. Yeah. Yep.
So I saw the movie yesterday and I
thought it really captured that sort of
desire to create the future that so
many of us at Google ended up here.
So then it was great to have a reminder of
that. So thanks for that. Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
So this is about the movie.
So Governor Nixon, the movie sort of seem
to be the last person in tomorrow, and,
and I'm curious, did he just
stack rank everybody else else?
Uh, we don't wanna we don't want
to spoil anything in the movie,
but I do think that, um,
uh, the idea that this is,
this was a place that was built to be
highly inclusive or, or open source,
um, uh, it was definitely in the
design. You know, he's speaking,
these are the things, um, and, but,
but there is this, uh,
you know, uh, again,
I have an eight year old son and when we
have kids come over from other families
and they have younger siblings,
he's like,
the younger siblings are not allowed in
my room because they are going to break
things and they are going to touch
things and they going to drool on them.
And I think that, you know, uh,
I think that Hugh Laurie's character
embodies many of these same ideas and he's
not wrong. That's, you know, uh,
that, that's the idea of like,
if you build something like this,
you can't be afraid that people are
going to come in and mess it up.
And when you become afraid that people
are going to come in and mess it up, you,
you closed the doors, you build
a large walls and uh, and,
and I think both sides are right. Um,
but, but it also have to see the movie,
but you have to see the
movie. Yeah. Thank you Brad.
I should see the movie.
Good. It, it help. It would,
it's about time.
So should, I haven't seen it yet,
but I'm interested in, um, as,
as writer and director,
how you strike the balance between a
concept which invites a lot of visuals,
just really rich,
incredible visuals and the intimacy
that in a story like how you keep people
connected personally when
there's a lot of, of,
let me just say one thing real quick.
W which is we made a conscious
effort in this movie.
I think a lot of movies have a cast,
a very large cast and they,
and they need to build
and build and build.
So that in the final set piece of
the movie, you've got, you know,
800 people fighting 800
other people. Um, we,
we made a real other 7,000
hundred CG generated.
We made a conscious effort
to really scale things down.
And that isn't to say that we didn't
want an exciting final act set piece,
but we said,
we're really in two hours.
We really only have the real estate
to get you to care about three or four
people and that, and, and that.
That way you're able to put a lot more
attention on the set piece and the
visuals itself. Right. But
I think that also, uh, the,
the quick answer to the visual question
is that all of this stuff needs to be in
service of the story and
the emotions of the story.
And so you don't just the city as a city,
you view it as a character that
also has an arc. And, and, uh,
hopefully, you know, each
character has an arc,
but the city itself has an
arc. And, uh, uh, I mean,
that's how you know,
you basically,
you try to simplify ideas so that you
can adhere to the skeleton that they
provide.
And like in Ratatouille I had the very
simple thing above my desk while I was
writing it that said, um, cooks
are givers and rats are takers.
And that helped me align all of the
scenes so that there was something
underneath them and on, on
this film, you know, we had uh,
ideas that are kind of complex,
but we had to come up with
a series of simple ways to,
to construct that idea and present it.
So it's keeping it simple
and keeping an emotional.
Thank you. Thank you. We have time for
about two more questions. We'll do it.
We'll do three.
Um,
you mentioned earlier that the future
sucks in a way that it didn't before.
It doesn't actually, can we just say that
our idea of the future that that yes,
if you go into the past that the future
was bright and shiny and things are
going to be better and now
things are going to be worse.
And this seems to be sort of a
general theme in our stories.
It's something happened. We
got all cynical. This happened
before I was born even.
But I have this that stink man.
It really does change that. Yeah,
I do build things. My question is,
it's a lot broader than the movie,
but why do you feel that happened? I know
it's sort of a really broad question.
There's probably no one simple answer,
but why do you think that happened?
Why did we drop our eyes
on the horizon like that?
Uh, well I, I think that
it's to see how I did that,
I think that there was a, there was
a philosophical shift away from, um,
I make the future happen, which,
which existed then and now. It's,
the future is something that happens to
me. It's very easy to be discouraged and,
and if, if, if everywhere you click,
it's basically telling you we've crossed
the point of no return in terms of
climate change.
It's very hard to motivate and say,
I'm going to reverse this process
because that is impossible.
And I think that generate
generationally. I was born in 1973, uh,
Jay, just as the troops were leaving
Vietnam. Um, I think that the,
the idea of there was a war,
a great war that happened in the middle
of the past century, that Wa that we, uh,
you know, that, uh, there was a huge
victory, you know, for humankind.
I'm not just Americans,
but just sort of this idea of we came
to the brink and we won. And, and I,
and I think that sort of, uh, things
have gotten a lot muddier since then.
The clear delineation between good and
evil has gotten a lot muddier and it's,
it's,
it's just much harder to get motivated.
It's much harder to be idealistic
without being shouted down.
But mostly it's the comments
section. Um, you know,
it's the God damn comment section.
Just look below me right now.
This is on youtube.
Look down and you will know
what happened to our future.
They're just taking it as
look down to, yeah, exactly.
Hi Brad. Daymond, first of all, this
is a great honor to meet you guys.
I'm big fans of you. And on
the piggyback, what you said,
being a veteran coming back, um, I
feel after World War II, you're right,
everyone felt that war and
was it like entrenched in it?
But coming back it felt like everyone
else and feel the same thing I felt.
So it's, it's interesting. It's like
this intangible thing. I can't explain,
but going into my question.
Um,
you had mentioned bugs bunny and like
adults exits accessing the animators
medium.
How do you feel about you ever maybe
tackling anime as a medium or any other
mainstream director?
Okay.
Well, I mean to me, uh,
a lot of anime is just, just really
great staging and more adult themes,
you know, but it's still using this,
the graphic power of the medium.
And, uh, you know, I, uh,
I don't feel the need to try to imitate
what they're doing cause they're always
going to do it better than I would.
But I do learn,
try to learn some lessons from it
and, and as I do from all film, um,
and I just think that, um, uh,
people make the mistake of calling
animation a genre and it isn't,
it's a medium that can do any
genre. And I think that, um,
I would love to see more different kinds
of animated films being made. I mean,
when a Pixar kind of made
it okay to do animation and,
and you know, with computers, um,
and also tell stories that
are more different than the,
there was a tendency to do everything
as a musical back then. And, uh, uh,
but then everybody started doing this
really crappy imitations of Pixar and that
becomes its own like
again,
you know,
it's a study of the laggy
blue and it is and it's good.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
There's always some little thing of them
dancing at the end in the ads and it's
just like, ah. Anyway, ah, anyway,
it's a wide open medium
that can do a lot of it
things.
I think Miyazaki has shown that.
And I would love to see people trying
more different things with animation,
you know? Um, so, uh, I want
to do other animated films.
I have ideas that, that I want to do.
I have one that's a science fiction,
the animation thing that I want to do
that kind of verges on what you're talking
and you have the dancing one?
No, no, I had birds dancing.
Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
Yeah. But anyway, uh, I,
my ideal career would be
be able to just back back
and forth between the two.
Thank you both. Thank you.
Last question. Hi. I was,
I just saw the trailer and I was felt it
was really exciting and different and I
was just curious how it got there,
the trailer for the trailer for tomorrow.
And what was the question? I'm sorry.
Uh, I had just seen the trailer,
the one that was before vendors.
It was long.
It was a single scene and it felt very
different from all the other trailers I
had seen recently. Yeah, I was just
wondering how it, how that happened.
Well,
I think that the goal,
both Damon and I don't like to
have surprises, uh, blown, but you,
you have to show something and you wanted
to lay a little track for it. So yeah,
I think that the first,
the,
the first phase of storytelling was that
we wanted to sell wonder, um, Eh, and the,
and the first trailer was
really just as simple as yes,
this young woman touching a pen and seeing
this place and George Clooney saying,
do you want to go with no sense of,
of what the story was.
But we eventually evolved to
a point where, um, people, uh,
we wanted to tell them a little bit
more about the story. Most importantly,
that if you want to get to this place,
there's going to be an obstacle.
There's going to be an impediment because
a place like this is going to have
people who don't want you to come in.
And so that piece of storytelling,
this whole sequence that took
place at Frank Walker's house,
where obviously these, uh, evil
robots are trying to kill people,
I think obviously certainly to,
uh,
to a broader audience that that's
massively appealing. But as Brad said,
it doesn't give anything away. It
doesn't spoil any of this surprise. Yeah,
I think that that,
um,
the quick way to describe the
story is that a girl touches a pen.
She's shown a place that is amazing and
then the pin stops working and she wants
to get back to that place.
It leads her to the Frank
Walker characters played by
George Clooney who's been
there and for some mysterious
reason doesn't want to go back.
So [inaudible] like, why is
that? And stuff like that.
But anyway, I'm happy you like
it and hope that you see it.
Yeah, I plan to. Sorry. All right,
excellent. Thank you. All right,
so let's think a brand
naming for being here.
[inaudible] thank you guys
so much for coming up with this as well.
So tomorrow land will be
released in theaters on Friday,
May 22nd and once you see it and love it,
you can also preorder it on Google
play on the same day that's released.
So we released later this year.
So,
but you can preorder it there on Google
play and a Hashtag tomorrow land for all
your g plus Twitter posts on social
media and go out and explore the world of
tomorrow land at, take me to tomorrow,
land.com so awesome. Thanks. On that time.